have you ever been in jail not not out
shoot talking about
I didn't have you been arrested sure
have been and I spent almost two days
sleeping on the floor yeah
and holding court and they called
started to call me professor cuz I was
like trying to I can't matter what I'll
hold you know me hold we I was a 30-7
what'd you do I got in a fight really
yeah and they put you in jail uh yeah
the cops are watching it to see what
these guys were bothering yes New York
yeah it's New York also got picked up
for talking to prostitutes and they were
cops and did not solicit prostitutes I
did not solicit one you're just gonna
talk to nope I literally they were these
two hot girls I swear to god this is so
funny I'm told this story on the bug did
I yeah okay no you can keep going to me
I'll I'll a dildo
well they said how much I said said you
have any money I knew I said I got
$5,000 honey joking around I was on my
way home I look I got no problem having
sex with a prostitute done it before in
this case I was not and I go to the ATM
to get money for a cab guess who's
waiting for me the cops I go I'm getting
money for a cab they go out sorry buddy
or you're under arrest I was like ah and
the girls a supple overcome so much sir
you talk to prostitutes then you go to
get money for the yeah
they were in a car and I was on my way
home distant I would never there's
nowhere to go with them I was gonna take
my parents house there was no I was in
the hotel yeah good looking they called
me over the car they saw there was
entrapment those [ __ ] and I'm like
yeah hey ladies and I'm looking at the
moment look at their legs and stuff like
that and and I could tell they were they
were kind of it was awkward and one of
them was skinny the main one talking me
I was like not not attractive and I go
across the street to the ATM and they're
waiting for me these [ __ ]
that's not if that's not fair and I even
said to them I go they and the guy goes
you got caught up you got caught up in
the [ __ ] weed you got caught in this
way there's nothing we can do and then
I'm sitting next to this poor guy who
was dressed like a woman he was this guy
and they were telling him to take his
nail polish off and he was scraping the
nail polish off and they were calling
him Tootsie and I got mad at the cops
like oh guys [ __ ] give him a break
man come on he see ya he's like I'll
take the
dressed like a woman go to jail yeah
they were gonna [ __ ] with yes I got a
doggy
don't go I'd take nail polish on he was
so nervous he's this big fat guy
probably in his 40s and I said to him I
go I start talking to me because I like
doesn't look like a broad sometimes it's
all just like dressing up like a broad
I'm not gay I just you know that's what
I like to do sometimes I was talking
about so wrong with that yeah he had his
own fetish he was a sweet guy probably a
broken man I ate some pie had a job he
hated and he was just trying to get out
and feel alive and they these you know
the New York cops or Irish Italian guys
macho dudes the not worry guys macho
muscular guys and you know they're
they're gonna make fun of you they were
they were doing it like they were like
this they were violent they were like
together that I could see hey tell [ __ ]
in there and he could hear it and I
could hear it and it was a bummer and I
and I I scolded them you know talking on
my guys they kind of didn't was not
making fun but tell them to I came in
you're you're going to New York [ __ ]
jail yeah just like a chick yeah all the
homies you can try [ __ ] your mouth
they don't though you're in the you're
in the [ __ ] you you're when you're in
the holding cell like that you're
waiting for to get processed and then I
saw this one dude it was his third
strike and he's talking to his girl like
mommy
mmm and they got me a mountain town you
got to tell him that I was at home
literally it that I got Jesus Christ a
nerd strike and a mold detect this came
and took him out those hardcore
detectives you see those detectives and
you're like oh you guys have seen some
[ __ ] Dada Dada I say come in you're in
trouble oh yeah my father said that my
father said to these guys and when he
worked with Citibank these guys who were
bankers thought it was really awesome to
manipulate the computers where they
would get one cent off of every check
that was deposited and so they had like
millions of dollars and my dad was in
there my dad tough-guy marine you know
things he said he said let me tell you
something if you think you can if you're
just a civilian and you think that you
can kind of play stone face with cops
like Oh guys you know real detectives
like you think you can like kind of I'm
gonna talk to my lawyer I'm not saying
[ __ ] these [ __ ] cops the he said
these FBI guys were just they're
professionals they've seen it all yeah
and you're quaking in your boots and
you've embezzled RL three million
dollars and they're just a regular guard
a lot of time but when it comes that
point they have so many fast yeah
me stories yeah I kind of know a bit of
the story when they come in he said he's
got so as soon as you go a weird way
they're like that never happened they
were crying so hard they didn't ask for
their lauren like when i was a kid my
dad he gave me any attention they're
like yeah should the [ __ ] I just
literally grow mad like I really they we
know you're a good person but you did
this and that's why we want to help you
yes okay I would like you do your friend
yeah help us help you man yeah there's a
murderer out there don't you care about
your friends yeah then tells like really
yeah this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]